this is Joma
[Music]
he's a software engineer turned YouTuber
and he left his job at Google to pursue
his passion acting and directing and his
place is a mess I'm actually going
through a similar career transition
right now and because I can relate to
him a little bit I decided to help him
out in this video I'm going to show you
the process of transforming his
apartment into a space that feels like
home because living in a space that you
love it can have a huge impact on the
quality of your life I'll be using my go
to app more folio Trace who I'm super
excited to be collaborating with for
this video if you're interested in any
of these assets I'll leave the link in
the description hey everyone my name is
dammy and I'm an architect in Vancouver
BC Joma lives on the other end of the
coast in New York City
[Music]
this is Joma and this is my apartment in
New York City come on in his apartment
is really messy there's a lot of random
stuff lying around everywhere and
there's no method to how things are
organized this actually gives him
anxiety I think a part of him believes
that chaos is an inevitable part of
creativity and I think this kind of
stems from his background he was a
software engineer which is a completely
logical kind of skill set and profession
and he did a total 180 and went into
something completely opposite which is a
creative Endeavor and so I get the sense
that for him creativity doesn't really
have a structure or method and I think
because there's no method there's a
little bit of fear but his ideas can
just slip away at a moment's notice and
that's why he has all of these things
around him for him to get inspiration
from from and for the objects to
communicate with him or maybe he's just
freaking lazy what are these these are
like a bunch of masks that I wanted to
use for video but I didn't end up using
them so now it's just junk I feel bad
like dumping something that I haven't
used
when I see a space all I see is the
struggle of being an artist and none of
the fun parts and so I really want to
design a space for him that makes him
happy to work where he can have a little
bit of structure for his creative
process but at the same time have a lot
of flexibility for the chaos like
organize chaos I think a small part of
me thinks that is how I think I have
like a chaotic mind I'm such an artist
you know what I mean this is how I come
up with ideas so I don't want something
that's clean because I would be scared
that I will lose my creativity the
current state of my apartment is who I
am but it's not ideal and it's not the
person I want to become but it's good
we're like starting from a fresh slate
this phase of the process is called
programming this is where you try to
identify all of the constraints of the
project if there's any existing
conditions the client's needs the
clients wants their Lifestyles their
habits even their taste and the more
answer you can get in this phase the
better chance you're going to have of
coming up with a good design later on
when you first come back home what do
you do how you use the space what your
typical day kind of looks like like do
you have like a specific setup what do
we have to keep absolutely if you're
designing someone's home try to learn
not just about how they use the space
but try to also learn about their habits
and their personality because you don't
want to design something that's not
going to work for them realistically so
yeah I am a perfectionist as in I'm
scared of putting things out there
because I'm scared I won't be accepted I
am Ultra critical of my work in a way
that it like cripples me a little bit
yes and lastly I'll do a kind of a rapid
fire feel test and this is a process
that I kind of came up with because I
found that people love doing yes or no
questions I use this to get a feel for
their preference for style or color or
mood um so like don't even think about
it just like left right right right
uh right whoa okay right right left left
right right right
am I taking too long
uh left but it's just like the fact that
it's kind of inviting but it seems to
have a lot of utility there's you know
it seems like it's worked on I think
that's very cool
a lot of people ask do I need to be good
at math do I need to be good at drawing
I think you don't really need to be good
at either of them but it helps a lot if
you are someone who likes talking to
people or likes learning about other
people so we are going to be focusing on
this area we do have a pretty
interesting set of constraints here
um well first of all the unit is laid
out pretty poorly you have this entire
space that's just hallway and you have
these weird jogs that make it really
hard to place furniture
and we also have this baseboard heater
that sticks out 10 inches and this ledge
which in total eats up about 20 inches
of the space in the living room but that
is the space that we are going to be
working with
he uses this area on the floor to do
physiotherapy and he has a storage unit
right here
and a storage unit right here that is
just annoyingly misaligned from this
wall he has this couch right here which
he rarely uses like look at it there's
so much crap on it
and he said he sometimes uses it for
when he's filming interviews where he
makes people feel really uncomfortable
but most of the time it's really rarely
used so I think that's gonna be a
challenge just to make this space a
little bit more livable by the way if
you guys want to learn more about this
origami iPad cover I'll leave the link
in the description
this is where he spends most of his time
90 of his time on this desk over here
and over here he has his second desk
which he rarely uses but he insists we
need to keep it because he needs to use
it for filming scenes where he's playing
two different characters overall the
space is as you can see very very messy
so I think one of the things is just
giving him a little bit of a hierarchy
for organization
so in my design process I usually use a
combination of more folio and SketchUp
for my design and presentation I rarely
bring it into a drafting software unless
things have been more or less finalized
because I can do iterations and design
options much much quicker this way
morfolio is designed specifically for
Architects and designers so it's got a
lot of functions that a lot of other
sketching apps don't like the super
scale feature is a game changer because
it allows you to sketch in scale a lot
of times when you're sketching on paper
unless you're really really really
precise with the scale what looks okay
on paper usually doesn't translate into
reality but with this you don't need to
bring it into a drafting or modeling
software because your drawing is exactly
to scale
having two desks is obviously a little
extra so I did ask him as in if I had to
choose between a second desk and a
living area based on your vision of
yourself of the grown-up drama not work
baby
the archetype part of me really wants to
convince him to get rid of one of those
desks because that's ridiculous to
especially in such a small space to have
two desks one of which you only use for
filming but the YouTuber side of me
understands how hard it is to set up a
scene and how much time and effort it
takes and so having a permanent setup it
can make the filming process so much
more smooth and so I think I'm just
gonna try to work around these
constraints so I think there's a couple
of options for the desk arrangement we
could try to keep it similar to how he
already has it with
the second desk here the primary desk
here
and his couch here
so we could try to Cluster the desks an
L configuration
with the desk along the glazing and the
couch here or we can do it this way
or we can do it
this way
the problem with all of these
configurations is that when you sit down
the couch is basically just looking at
the back of the desk which is not a
great View
so I just don't see this couch being
used he also said he rarely has people
over and he usually just uses the couch
for doing those interviews honestly I
feel like it's a little bit of a waste
of space so what if instead of having an
entire couch we just had
two armchairs that way the view is not
towards the living room but he can
actually look out
also when he's doing interviews he can
sit here the guests can be sitting here
and they can have the camera facing this
way
if you want to take a break from his
computer and go read on his iPad or go
read a book or something he can use this
as a lounging area so this area is more
for Focus work and this area can be more
for diffuse work and your creativity
actually benefits a lot from going back
and forth so I really like this idea of
having the arm chairs here so that kind
of leaves us with two options this one
or
this one this option you could film with
this wall as the backdrop it would be a
different kind of office scene but it
could definitely work and this way he
can have his entire area over here for
doing yoga or physio so I'm gonna try to
develop
these two options this one and this one
a little bit more in detail
so this is the elevation facing the wall
I'll bring this into more folio trace
and start sketching on top of that using
their perspective guides which is super
helpful for quickly and accurately
sketching out ideas I want to do like an
upper level of storage where he can keep
things like he rarely needs or things
that he wants to keep on display
and I think this also kind of helps to
Define this area and that's kind of what
I want to do I want to Define this
entire zone for his creative work where
he can kind of spread out you know throw
his ideas around and kind of get messy
so I've wrapped this entire area with
cork board so you can pin things as he's
working but I think he also needs
another level of storage you know
something that he can see and he's going
to get anxiety because he doesn't know
where things have to go I've used this
Ikea solution in my office as well but I
really like the status because you can
use different shelves and hooks and it's
a really great solution for keeping
small items
foreign
could be to have the shallow shelves
here and continue that over onto the
side this over here feels a little bit
like a waste of space so I think I'll
just put in like another lower shelf
here but I think because this side is
right next to his desk I think it's
actually a really good spot for him to
pin his ideas on and I like this as like
an extension of the desk so I'm going to
remove these shelves and put the tack
board back here
[Music]
and in fact I don't know how much he's
going to be using the tack more behind
his computer so you know maybe I'll just
use this for additional storage
[Music]
now the second option is closer to what
he has right now where the desks are
across from each other I really like
this idea of using this Nook as an
extension of his workspace so I'm going
to leave this cork board here and I'm
going to place the desk along the edge
of the wall so that we can use this for
shelving and actually we can have a
drawer unit here which we couldn't
before because we had the desk in the
way I'll use the narrower Ikea boards
here as well by the way he said he never
uses the standing desks in the standing
position so I'm not really worried about
these boxes getting in the way then I'll
actually do another drawer here
foreign
[Music]
so this is the opposite elevation
right now he has this shelf here
but the problem is when you're walking
in from the hallway this blocks The View
into the living room and especially in a
small space you want to try to have as
much sight lines as possible so I'm
going to split the storage into two I'm
gonna do an upper
and I'll do a lower so you still can
have this Clear Sight line across the
room when you enter the unit I'm
aligning this upper shelf to the ceiling
Jog and 14 inches down from that
[Music]
so what I've done is on the side I'm
keeping open shelving Which is closest
to his workspace and over here I'm gonna
have closed drawers or cabinets I'll do
another attack board here for his photos
which he said he really wants to keep
and I left the space in between these
two shelves so that he can place any
straight elements like his fan his
vacuum his lights or his tripod and
there's some much much higher chance of
him putting it back here if it's out
here in the open and I think creating
this little Nook for these three
elements feels a little bit more
intentional and tidy over here I'll have
a little space for some of his artwork
and paintings as a conversation piece
the other option is of course without
the desk with the desk on the other side
so I'll put in another lower shelving
unit here and try to find one that
matches the height of the ledge of the
heater and it becomes a part of this
section and over here in the hallway I'm
gonna put in a shoe rack and some coat
hooks and some hooks for his keiths on
the other side the unit actually comes
with these wall sconces so I'll put in
some artwork in between these to make
the entry feel a little bit more
welcoming when he comes home so now I'm
gonna package all of this up and I'm
going to prepare a quick presentation
for Jomo if you want to find out how
things went stay tuned for the next
video I'm also really curious because I
have no idea how he's going to respond
[Music]